[Music]
foreign
yeah you know it's it's it's cool uh
it's really cool I mean again maybe back
to that football coach thing but it's
it's it's [__] really cool to sit
down with you like this man and and uh
see you like this and like you know
because it it you know it always was a
little bit for me you know you know
again I felt so like protected and and I
always felt loved by you I always felt
like even just like you choosing me was
just such it was such a huge thing for
me man I took it so seriously such a
miracle in my life you know and like
getting to do that
but I also like and I didn't know
whether it was the movie or not but I
always felt like man like you know you
it's there was always this thing like
you know you could you could never
really get in never really open up there
like you would see that like he's the
boss man he's a [__] gangster like
he's a real gangster like the way he
handles himself like I'd seen that but I
also this unbelievable ability to like
break people down and open them up and
like and talk about the most intricate
and and and and most like a net no
filmmaker no artist I've ever worked
with has been able to like you know play
play people's [__] chords of the most
intricate every ounce of the pain where
the pain and the Darkness is like just
as beautiful as is dark and like so
fascinated by it but yet so like you
ain't gonna get there with me and I see
like and and you and and and just talk
just a little bit man and we don't have
to go but like like just a little bit
about Kev and and just because he's he
you know I think he means just like a
ton to everyone in this room and like
you know you brought Kevin into my life
but like who is Kevin you and like the
work that you guys have done and Kevin
Vance
um yeah uh
known him a minute uh
uh Madam in a parallel life and uh
watching him
transform because like when I'm when I
met him he was just in it yeah like like
and he had had that you know hangover of
like
the military
um I mean the secret to the military is
like a handful of people do all the work
right so it's like oh we have all these
Army divisions well they're kind of just
holding Security on the Edge at the end
of the day while you know this handful
of very highly trained
amazing people it kind of gets it done
at
incredible
moral hazard blowback cost to self and
and he was like
one of the first people I've met from
that community
it was so funny because you know when I
met him he was like solving the
community and solidly in that
identity I am an elite operator that is
who I am yeah and
and he evolved out of that and didn't
need that to be his identity and then
went on this healing journey and started
helping people like right left and
center and was really a [__] Pioneer
now and now he's out there like like
trying to save lives rescuing people
because yeah these dudes in these
communities
they take so much trauma on our behalf
massive amounts of trauma and they do
really dark things on our behalf
and that whole Warrior culture has its
own thing going on
and it's not a safe space to like be
invulnerable and talk about your heart
and and you know okay here you are
whacking people out and now you're
vulnerable and talking about your heart
you know
and I've seen it in the gang world too
where the homies are like
becoming conscious you know and like we
used to be achievement back Australia
cavemen and now it's like oh we're
humans and we have this holistic life
and can impact people
and there's something about people that
have seen that extreme violence and
lived in it and been around it that
pushes them closer towards a bigger
human truth and they bring that back
into the regular life and that's why
I've always connected with that because
it's I felt like they're in the real
world and everyone else is in the fake
world [__] April I mean I I honestly
I think that more than anything else is
why like I'm trying to do this because
it's like look if I can
[__] hat like if you say that and and
like Kevin says that you know it's like
everybody else in their life can like
stop hiding behind all that [__] it's
like look look at who's saying it dude
and it's like look at the potential like
I know you've been through it but like
look at the potential for like look at
what you can create look at what you how
you can serve you know like that's it
right there is is how do you serve and
I'm wrestling my journey right now at
the moment it's just like like
am I worthy of serving you know and it's
like okay track record these movies
impact these communities of Health
people okay there's evidence there that
I am worthy to serve I would say so bro
I just got to figure it out but like
everything's ego you know like like
ego and Trauma and pain and how you
shape your personality to not feel the
pain you know and it's like
I don't know you know like like the
homies [__] gangsters right like
typically they're smart as [__]
they're like
rounded people like they see the world
in a different way
they have this specialized knowledge
about life and people
and
there there's a deep deep truth that
they find and especially the survivors
in that space and like the guys that
[__] hang and and that energy you
know like
There's Something Beautiful to it
and then if you can get away from all
the [__] I'm [__] this I'm not
oh okay how do I help the Young Guns how
do I help these families how do I like
people are talking about
trauma and [__] that's happening to him
when no one ever did before which is
amazing but like
it's self-rescue all these communities
have to self-rescue right because right
now
you know the way our society is
you know
it's the opposite of cohesion it's the
opposite of unity it's the opposite of
coming together so like all these
communities have to self-rescue there's
so many [__] agendas but if you can
just human connection and like
I don't know like like if I got whacked
out on the streets when I was like 18
doing dumb [__] right like there
wouldn't there wouldn't be these movies
that that have left a positive impact
and and it's like for all my like oh on
the back I'm a piece of [__] and I hate
myself and blah blah
I got it that's objective that that's
value in that that means I brought
something of value to this world and and
yeah man like if we can just get out of
these negative self-stories and and stop
doing that in all these communities and
and just hunt down these negative
narratives that are that are just tying
us to the ground like that's the way to
do it you you you you talk about your
own negative [__] and the [__]
that's like your own negative to
self-serve believe me I know it's so
[__] well but then the first thing
you said to like from from this
this omnipresent [__] view when you
look at it yeah but look at these look
at these things on the board that like I
know like have helped people or change
people right it's like I go through that
same [__] so in this National or
International whatever in this state
that we are right now what role does
does art play in in in in rescue arts
and nuclear weapon art is so
ridiculously [__] powerful the most
powerful medium is film right so you
have acting you're directing you have
music you have you have art Visual Arts
you know it's it's it's a collaboration
of multiple artistic mediums creating
this illusion of reality right and you
know it's like
like when I saw a Scarface for the first
time it must have been like nine or
something you know
and
for my world at the time it was like
there's a bigger more important world
there's a lot more going on than you
knew and people come in a lot different
shapes and varieties and abilities and
and then you knew and it was just like
this keyhole into this world right and
that's one of the reasons why art is so
controlled why the industry is so
controlled why everything is so
incredibly gate kept because God forbid
man this piece of primordial magic leak
through the system and transform the
world like I believe that you can create
something that can transform the world
instantly like it's that powerful it's
that powerful and that terrifies The
Gatekeepers and terrifies people that
that want these negative narratives
about ourselves to be out there you know
and want control of it for themselves
and want to be the only ones that do it
they say well it's [__] I mean I don't
know how's the world really work right
it's about money or is it not about
money you know what I mean and who has
the money who has the violence who has a
monopoly on violence who controls
violence like what what what is this
world what is this Society it's a
for-profit corporate [__] machine man
it is what it is you know how do you
find humanity inside of that how do you
you know and and I I believe that human
beings are
incredibly capable like like one of us
can change the world and and imagine if
we all got together and started
co-creating a positive reality together
like how transformative that would be
but if my entire
wealth my generational wealth is based
upon
you know keeping you nervous so you make
a consumer choice and buy my product to
satisfy that that emptiness in your soul
last thing I [__] want is some sort
of like mass self-realization and rising
up of humanity [__] that man you want to
smash you [__] and Shake you
upside down get all your money
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
and Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf
of both of us and everybody from the
real ones team I just want to sincerely
thank you guys for for tuning in the
folks that I bring on the show they're
family to me and uh being able to tell
their stories and bringing you into
their world is something I'm I'm just
super proud of and uh again grateful
that you guys tune in we've decided we
want to take things just a step further
it's a patreon community and basically
what that means is if you become a part
of this community look I already board
Bam Bam if you want to become a part of
this community you're going to be able
to hear episodes early and all that ad
free and all that good stuff but there's
all this behind the scenes footage all
this stuff that we've shot that really
brings you into the folks that we've had
on the show really brings you into their
world live chats with me and the folks
that I bring on the show to talk about
their world talk about the issues that
they're dealing with but their triumphs
and their tragedies just go to patreon
slash real ones on this website that you
see right there right on the screen
that's right in front of you this whole
idea year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll